this is a moment female activists in
Nigeria have worked for
a woman from a major political party
becoming a candidate for governor
and she is a front-runner
Aisha to binani overcame religious and
cultural barriers in the patriarchal
society to get here
she says it's been worth the struggle it
gives women
it gives our daughters and gives us
sisters our aunties our mothers the
confidence that yes oh so
a woman can walk towards occupying
whatever elective position they desired
although women make up half of Nigeria's
population they've long been on the
fringes economically and politically
we know also by virtue of the level of
Education
particularly in this part of the country
the women have been at the disadvantage
compared to men
but activists say changing attitudes and
their strength in numbers could work for
them this time
really time for women and we don't have
we don't want to miss this opportunity
we don't know when we'll get this
opportunity again
Nigeria's general election later this
month is being keenly contested and
closely watched
women activities across Nigeria
the presidency could be within reach
the outcome of the vote won't be known
for weeks but for now her supporters are
celebrating what they have already
achieved and say momentum is on their
side
Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera Yola